[موسيقى]
كل عام يتحلل ما يقرب من 30 مليون
فدان من التربة الخصبة إلى
أرض صحراوية غير صالحة للاستعمال ،
وهي عملية تُعرف بالتصحر مع
تغير
المناخ ، وقد تفاقمت المشكلة
وتهدد حياة أكثر من
مليار شخص في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، والمشكلة هي أنها تحدث تحت
أقدامنا  بعيدًا عن الأنظار
بعيدًا عن ذهنك ، لكن ماذا لو استطعت إعادة
تلك الأرض الصحراوية
إلى تربة خصبة في غضون
ساعات
تدعي شركة نرويجية ناشئة للتحكم في الصحراء
أن بإمكانها فعل ذلك تمامًا ،
فما هو الاختراع الحقيقي هنا
للسيطرة على الصحراء ، ما هي الصلصة السرية
لرجلك؟  لقد اخترعنا طريقة
لتحويل الطين إلى سائل
رقيق تقريبًا مثل طين خلط الماء في
التربة ، وقد استخدم منذ فترة طويلة لاستعادة
الأراضي الزراعية الجافة ، لكن العملية يمكن أن تستغرق من
سبعة إلى خمسة عشر عامًا لتكتمل
عن طريق تحويل الطين إلى سائل ،
يتم تقصير العملية بشكل كبير
تقوم الشركة ببساطة برش ما يسمونه
سائل النانو على أرض جافة
يتسرب تحت السطح ويبدأ
العمل في سبعة فقط
ساعات سوف تلتصق فقط بكل
حبة رمل موجودة في جميع أنحاء تلك التربة
ثم تشكل هذا الهيكل الذي
يمكّن التربة من الاحتفاظ
بالمياه والمواد المغذية تمامًا مثل الإسفنج
في التجارب المبكرة التي تديرها منظمة غير ربحية في
كوسة الحبوب والبطيخ بدبي التي تحتاج إلى 50
بالمائة  كمية أقل من المياه لزراعة
بعض النباتات حتى ازدهرت لدينا
زيادات في إنتاج الكوسة تصل إلى 62 في المائة
نتائج مبهرة حقًا ، لكن النانو السائل
ليس رخيصًا بين 8000 إلى 20000
فدان ولكن السيطرة على الصحراء تتوقع أن التكاليف
ستنخفض مع زيادة الشركة
بعد ذلك  عام ، هناك خطط لاختبار
التكنولوجيا في الولايات المتحدة
في الولايات الجافة مثل كاليفورنيا نيفادا وأريزونا ،
وأنت تعلم أن درجات الحرارة المتزايدة تزيد من
فترات الجفاف
حتى نتمكن من ضمان أن
كمية المياه القليلة التي احتفظنا بها بالفعل
في تلك
التربة ستكون شديدة للغاية  قيمة
ومهمة للمزارعين للمضي قدما